I have to say to that um that you know I
love your wife okay I do I think she is
there her but here yeah but no there's
no bot okay okay I wonder where this is
going there's no negativity okay all
right I really like the life you've
covered up carved out for yourself
you know thank you I know your parents
yes I know your brother you know your
wife is great your kids are [ __ ]
adorable I've never met them I get it I
get it
I've never met Ken's kid that's fine
yeah a lot of comics I've never I've
never met because they feel like they
think that I'm gonna like when Ike
Barinholtz had a family and this and
that it just we just stopped
you know I mean because he thinks that
I'm gonna pull my dick out no no no I
don't think that and I would never think
that I don't know Ike but I guarantee he
doesn't think that I think like I've
never met Ken's kids talked about each
other's kids and stuff but I think when
you have kids it's like I think the last
thing you want to do is like do one more
thing with your kids because you're so
exhausted and drained like today I I
spent a little bit of time with that I
haven't seen them and in within two
hours of my absolutely sacked absolutely
crippled I just want to like have dinner
get them to bed and then like have your
life back
Wow I think sometimes it's like you
don't want to bring that burden of
energy and no stop touch don't do that
stop hitting it you don't wanna bring
that around
ah is what it is yeah it's not that
you're gonna pull your dick out which
right you did has to me when you were
jerking up yeah yeah but we were comics
and adults and friends whoa do in front
of any friend yeah she's amazing with
kids I love kids
yeah and number two al Madrigal mm-hmm
and his wife made me dinner with his
kids they did the I did the little what
do they do with no they just a regular
handkerchief thing yeah right I did that
whole thing I put my utensils on the
side you know cuz I went to etiquette
school years ago did you really I did my
mom my parents threw me through a ticket
school what happened I was in a ballroom
I did a ballroom dance thing well though
in fact there is an
an old article they took a gigantic
photo of me in the newspaper San Diego
Union of me ballroom dancing with a
white girl you know man and so I learned
all that so when al Madrigal invited me
because no one no one's ever introduced
me to children yeah when he did it was
it really meant a lot you know because
he's like you know cuz I was like I love
kids and um you know so you know maybe
you and you guys can make me a dinner
uh-huh
sure I would do that with your kids yeah
and I won't swear I'll be all Christian
about it on our patreon episode
yesterday he asked my 10 year old niece
if she would kill anyone and for what
reason I was like well I don't know if
that's invitation send you some movies
it would end up with he'll learn you're
gonna learn one day but murder